hi everyone and welcome to a special
python tutorial
where we are going to learn how to
perform web scripting
so first of all thanks to free code cam
to giving me this opportunity
of being a guest on their channel and i
have a youtube channel as well that is
named gym shape coding
and you can find there any tech related
topic such as programming language web
development
and more content that i am uploading
once or twice a week
so you can just go ahead and find the
link from the description
okay so in this video i'm going to do my
best to teach you anything
that is related to web scripting and i'm
going to do that with the beautiful soup
library and that is a special library
that will allow you to gather any
information
you want from any website you want okay
so this website
could be your bank account could be a
job post website like linkedin
this could be wikipedia or a sports
website
and really anything that you can think
about so
we will start by scraping a basic html
page
first just to understand the concepts
and then we will move on to scraping
a real website and by the last 15 to 20
minutes of
this tutorial i'm going to show you how
you can store the information
that we have just pulled from this
website
so let's begin
great so this is the webpage that we are
going to start
web scraping and i'm going to explain
what is going on here so you can see
that we are having a basic title
and then we are having a kind of three
paragraphs
so you can see that we have a title of
python
and then we have a kind of secondary
title and then there is a basic
explanation
about the course itself and then we are
having a button
that says start that will probably lead
us to a different page if we click on it
and then you can see that it has the
price here
as well now we are kind of repeating
ourselves
three times here and this is what is
responsible to
that web development paragraph and then
also for that
machine learning paragraph now what we
are currently looking at
it is basically the behind the scenes of
that page
so this is the html code that is defined
in order to show you that hello start
learning page and
you can see that inside our html
documents all of the code
is being created with tags now those
tags
are what are responsible to display
different information for you
and you can see that we have a big tag
that is called html and then
inside of that html tag we are having a
head tag
and then a body tag now you can see that
we are defining a closure for each of
our tags
with the forward slash here and then you
are probably going to see that for
the different tags as well now let's
expand the head
tag here and then inside of it we are
seeing some meta information
that is not quite relevant for us but we
see that
link tag which is responsible to import
some styling for our page
and then we can see that title tag which
is responsible to customize our tab
name and that is why you'll see my
courses over here now i will
close back the head and then i will
expand the
body so the body is responsible to
display what is going to be on the page
itself it is the page's body and you can
see that we already have the
h1 tag that is created here and then
between the closure which is the area
that you can write
the text for that tag we see the hello
comma start learning
and then we are having some div tags
here and
when you see the tag of div this is the
very basic
tag that will create some tags
in different styling so you'll see here
the
class equals card what this attribute
assigning does here it is importing the
card
styling and that is why you see the kind
of
carding style for each of our
paragraphs over that page and you can
see that we are having one more div
inside that card class which is called
card header
so this is the styling for card header
this is why
it is called that way and then the text
is
python and then we have the card body
and we have the
h5 tag which is a kind of smaller header
that you can display
and if i scroll right here you can see
that python for beginners text and then
the closure for
hyh5 tag and we are having a paragraph
and then
the a tag which is allowing us to
lead to another page so when you see the
a tag
it is basically a reference to another
page that you can
visit now this entire code that i'm
currently marking
let's actually make our page a bigger
here
this entire code that i just marked is
kind of repeated
three times and that is why we see the
page that we saw previously okay so
it is quite important to understand and
we
are going to scrape that page and
pull some information with the beautiful
soup library
now if you are confused with the script
tags here
don't because those tags are responsible
to
import some javascript libraries and
that is something
not relevant for us right now okay so we
are going to switch to python now in
order to
apply some basic scraping for that page
so i will go and start working on my
main.pi
file and you can see that nothing is
here now before we actually start we
have to
install same libraries and one of them
will be the beautiful soup so i will
open my terminal
and since i'm working with my system
global interpreter
i will allow myself to install it over
here
and i will go here and write pip install
and then we will write here beautiful
soup
4 so make sure that everything is
not spaced or not split it with dashes
and then i'm going to
hit enter and then you can see that it
is installed
successfully and then the next thing
that i want to install
will be something that is going to be
used from the beautiful soup library
and that is the parcel method so when
you work with beautiful soup you have to
specify the method that you are going to
parse html files into python
objects okay so there are going to be
different methods
to parse your html code and
i heard that the best of them could be
the lxml
parser since if you work with the
default html parser
it is not going to deal well with broken
html code
so just go ahead and install the lxml
parcel library
and you can also do that with pip
install and then we are going to
use that when we work with the beautiful
soup so
i will go here and then write pip
install
lxml and then once i do that
let's wait until it's finished great so
we are ready now to
go back to python and start working with
the beautiful soup library
now we have to go here and import that
beautiful soup library
so it could be a little bit confusing
because the
libraries folder is created as bs4
so that is why we are going to write
here from
bs 4 import beautiful
soup like this and once i have done that
i have to figure out how i'm going to
access the content
inside the home.html file that is
right there inside my web scraping
directory so in order to do that we have
to
work with file objects now if you don't
know how to work with files in python
that is totally fine because we are
going to go over it
and it also might be worth to check my
channel out
if i have already uploaded how to work
with files
in python so i'm going to write here
with open so this is basically a
statement
that will allow me to open a file and
then
read the content of that specific file
so as you can see from the
autocompletion
i have to specify as my first argument
the file's name
so i'm going to close the parenthesis
here and then
inside here i'm going to write my html
files name now since the python file and
then the home.html file
are in the same exact directory it will
be okay just to
write its name so it will be home.html
and the second argument will be the
method that
you want to apply when you open that
file in that python's memory
so you have couple of options when you
work with python files
you can read them you can write them or
you can do
both and if we only want to read the
content
then we somehow want to specify that we
only want to
read this file so we will open here a
new string
and we will write here r so what this
tells to python
is basically that i'm going to read that
file only
and once i have done that i have to
write here a variable that is going to
be
used inside that code block that i just
created
which is the with open so i'm going to
use the
as keyword and then i'm going to create
here a variable name that is going to be
used
throughout the block of the open so it
will be
html underscore file and that will be
basically
my variable name and then once i do that
i will go inside the open block
and then i will write here content
equals to html file dot read
and once i apply the read method i'm
basically
reading the html file content
and in order to show you how this works
let's
first print the content itself so i will
go here
and print the content and then i will
run out the
main.pi and then you can see that the
information that
is printed is exactly what we saw
in the home dot html okay so
we kind of did a great job reading this
file
now in my future episodes we are going
to
read html files from real websites but i
just want to
give you an idea of how web scraping
works
in a very basic way because when you
work with actual websites
the scraping and the information pulling
is going to be quite harder
than the html file that i just have
written
in order to explain the idea of web
scraping okay
so i'm going to continue on here and i'm
going to
use the beautiful soup library in order
to
prettify my html and work with its
tags like python objects so
the way you can accomplish that will be
by creating an instance of beautiful
soup and i
will go here and create a new variable
let's call it
soup and that is going to be equal to a
new
instance of the beautiful soup library
now the
arguments that i'm going to specify here
will be the html file that i want to
scrape so the content of that will be
the content variable that
is created up above and then the second
argument
will be the parser method that we want
to use so
we will pass the password method as
string
and that will be the lxml that we have
just
installed previously now once i go
ahead and try to print what is inside
that
soup instance it will be something like
the following so
we will create here a print statement
and then
we will go with soup dot pretify
so that will allow you to see the html
code
in a more pretty way and if i go ahead
and run this you can see that we see the
html content
that is exactly the same like what we
saw in the home.html so we have done a
great job
until now so let's minimize back our
terminal
and now we are going to get more
familiar with the special methods that
are created
inside the beautiful soup library so we
are going to delete the print from here
and we are going to start working how we
can grab some specific information that
we want to grab so let's assume that we
want to grab
all the html tags that are created as
h5 tags which is a kind of header tag so
we will go here and create a new
variable let's call it
tags for example and then we will go
with soup
dot find and then once i go with find it
is going to search for the specific html
tag
that i'm going to specify here as a
string
so if i go here and write h5
and then down below i go ahead and
print the tags the results of that will
be something like the following now you
can see that we have the entire html tag
for the h5 tag as you can see that its
text is python for beginners
but if you remember we have more than
one
h5 tags that are created inside our home
html tag so if you remember from the
home file
there is one here there is the second
one over there
and there is the third one over there
and
what that means it means that the find
method
searches for the first element and then
it stops the execution
of searching for the html tag that you
are looking for
now if you want to change this behavior
and
not only grab the first element then
basically you have to
change your method into find underscore
all okay so that will search for all the
h5
tags inside the content and now if i go
ahead and run
that out then you can see that the
result here is quite different
as we have here a list and then you can
see that
it has python for beginners and then
also
python web development and then also the
python
machine learning now that could be a
great logic to bring you back all the
courses names
from that web page so you can go here
and
change this into courses
html tags okay so this is what the
h5 tags are actually responsible for and
now i can
write here some different code that will
allow me to
see all the courses that are defined
on our page so we have python for
beginners
and then we have python web development
and then we
also have python machine learning so we
can
work with these courses html tags that
stores all the h5
html tags and write a next program that
is going to display all the courses
so we can actually create here an
iteration
over the course of html tags because it
has a list
so we will go here with four course
in courses html tags and then
inside of that course tag that we are
iterating
we can bring only the text attribute
which is going to display the course
text itself so it will be here course
dot text and now if i go ahead and
run our program then you can see that we
have a nice
output regarding all of the courses that
are available
from that page so this could be a nice
starter to
understand how you can scrape a web page
to
grab some specific information you want
all right so
we were able to understand how we can
apply some basic scraping to
a web page but when you are going to
deal with real websites
the html code is not going to be quite
friendly and simple
like we had here so in order to
be able to access the html code behind
the scenes of some
page we have to use the inspect of any
browser so let's say that you want to
grab the
price for each of the courses so
it makes sense to go with your mouse and
hover to that button
and then right click on it and then you
want to look for that
inspect option and once you open that
out you will have a new pane
that is going to be opened and then here
we can see all the html code
that is responsible to display what is
going on
on the left pane so you can see that we
have here let's make it a little bit
more bigger
so that will be enough and then you can
see that we have here
div class card three times which is
displaying all the different courses
now when you go over different html tags
with your
mouse you can see that it is going to
mark for you the html tag
that is related to it so it is a quite
important behavior that we should
understand
now let's say that we want to grab the
price for that python for beginners so
it makes sense to
expand this tag and see what is inside
so i will go here and search for that
button and you can see that this a tag
is actually responsible
for that button itself and then you can
see that
its text is start for twenty dollars so
the price information is right there
and let's actually write a program that
is going to
search for that python for beginners and
then we will grab the
price for that course and then we will
be able to write a nice program
that is going to include a list of all
of the courses
and then the prices for each one of them
so let's go back to pycharm
and write this program so we will go
here and
delete everything from here and
the first step that we probably want to
do
is to be able to grab all the course
cards
so it will be course underscore
cards equals to soup that
find underscore all because we probably
are looking to bring us back all the
cards so this is why you have to use
find all
and not define and i'm going to search
for the
div tags now it could be much nicer if
we
could filter the div tags that we
actually
want to grab and store it inside our
course cards
so if you noticed let's go back to our
courses
page and here if i just expand
back there all the div tags you can see
that there is something that
is common for all the div tags their
class is equal to card so i can filter
my div tags by this expression
right there so i go back to pycharm
and i will write here class equals to
card but now you can see that there is
an error and it is quite important
behavior to understand
you have to apply here the underscore
because the
class is a built-in keyword in python
where you create python classes so that
is why you have to add the underscore
over here and then the beautiful soup
will understand that you are relating
to the class of the html attribute okay
so it is important
now since we have all the course cards
stored
right in this variable then we probably
want to iterate over this list
and then search for the course name and
then the course price
so let's see how we can do that for each
of our course cards
so we will start with for loop here and
that will be four course in
course cards and before we go ahead and
write some more code inside
our for loop let's actually remind you
what is inside each of our
courses and then you can see that we
have h5 tags
on each of our course cards and it makes
sense to access
this specific h5 tags so we can
accomplish that
by going here and then use the h5
tag as an attribute so if i go ahead and
press here
dot h5 and re run my program
then you can see that we were able to
grab each of our h5 tags
that are inside the course card so it is
a quite
great thing and now if i revert this
back to course again and run that out
you can also see that inside our a tags
we have the text for start for 20
dollars
and that is repeated for all of our
cards as well
so first of all it makes sense to delete
this again
and right here something like course
name equals to course
dot h5 and then here we probably look
for the text attribute
of that h5 tag so i will
write here dot text and then this course
name will be responsible to store the
text on each iteration so it is
great and now i can go here and
write course price and then this time i
will search for
course dot a because the a tag stores
the information
about the course price so until now
if i go ahead and print the course name
and then i also go ahead and print the
course
price then we will see the results like
the following
so you can see that we have python for
beginners
and then we have the a tag itself but in
this case we
look for the text of that a tag as well
so
i will minimize my terminal out and
excuse me for that i will delete that
from here
and then search for the text attribute
over here as well
and now i will run my program and then
you can see that
we have python for beginners and then we
have the text for
each of our a tags and now since we
reached
this stage it might be a greater idea to
print a sentence
like python for beginners costs 20
dollars okay so
the way we can do that is basically
using the
split method to access that last element
of that text because the price is
located
as the last word so it makes sense to
go here with split and then we will
split it by the blank so we don't have
to specify anything here
and we want to grab that last element so
we are looking for
-1 index over here and now if i run it
you can see that we have the price for
each of our courses and now it might be
much
nicer if we go ahead and use
an f string to print a dynamic sentence
for each of our cursors so we will go
here with print
and then we will open an f-string and
then we will access the
course name so it will be course
underscore name
and then we will write costs and then we
want to display the close price so it
will be
cool underscore price now if i
run our program then you can see that it
displays a nice information about each
one of the courses
now if you think about it that is a
quite nice behavior that we have applied
here
because if you scrape a real website
like udemy
that keeps updating courses then it
might be a great idea to
launch this program every certain amount
of time
for example each week and then you have
the ability to be aware
about each of the courses that udemy has
updated
on the webpage that you scrape on so
this is a quite nice behavior that we
were able to
reach here
on this one we are going to scrape real
websites with the
requests library so i'm going to
simulate this against a website
that is going to search for job
advertisements
and i'm going to bring all the jobs from
a specific website
that their main skill requirement
is python programming language and i'm
going to write a program
that is going to pull the latest
published job advertisements
from a specific website so it is going
to be very interesting so
let's get started all right so one of
the first things that we must do
is to ensure that we have the request
library installed
so i'm going to go down to my terminal
right in pycharm and i'm going to write
here
pip install request just to make sure
that i have the request library
installed now the output for myself
could be different than yours because
you may not have the request library but
since i already have that
you can see outputs like requirement
already satisfied okay so it is quite
important
now i'm going to minimize the terminal
and
right here import requests so you want
to make sure that you do that after the
installation of this library
and the first thing that i'm going to do
here
is to use the get method of the
request library now what request library
is doing behind the scenes it is just
requesting information from a specific
website
so it is like a real person going to a
website
and requesting some information okay so
you can
go with something like the following
when it comes to
request library so it will be request
dot
get so you want to get specific
information from a website
and here we are going to provide an
empty string
for now but later on we are going to
complete this string with the
url that we are going to web script
against it
and i'm going to assign this to a new
variable and i will call it html
text so i'm going to make that to be
equal to
this entire statement now let's go to
a web browser and look up for the
website that is going to include some
job ads okay so this is timejobs.com
and this website includes job posts
about almost everything so you can
simply go
down here and search for some skill that
you own
and then this will search for you jobs
that are requiring
this specific skill in that position now
this video is recorded a couple days
before when i uploaded it
so if you watch this video after a
couple of months or even a year or two
since the publish date then there is a
great chance that the html elements are
going to be
quite different but the main point of
this video
is to teach you all the tools to pull
information from a website
just as you want and then you can apply
your own customizations
and kind of doing a reverse engineering
to the code that i'm going to
write throughout this tutorial great so
let's go
here and write python so i will receive
only job posts about this programming
language
and you can see that we have this job
found
over there and we have a lot of jobs
that are published
so my goal here in this tutorial
would be to let's get this closed
so my goal in this tutorial will be to
bring all the jobs that are posted
a few days ago so if i am zooming here
in then you can see that we have
posted a few days ago for a couple of
posts
but after i reach down here we have
posted four days ago
so this might mean that this job post
is not the most updated so i'm going to
bring all the jobs and i'm going to
condition my program
to bring those elements with the posted
few days ago
text only so let's go back to
here now i'm going to bring this url
from here
and i'm going to paste that in in the
empty string that we
created inside the request.get and
once i have done that what is going on
inside
this variable right now is simply the
request code status okay so if i'm going
to
print the i mean if i'm going to run
this program
then we are going to see the results
like the following
so 200 is the convention number in
web that the request is done
successfully but in order to avoid the
status code
we are going to go to here and i'm going
to
accept the text only so i'm going to go
here and then write
dot text okay so this is what we have to
apply here
in order to bring the html text of
that specific page and now it makes
sense to
leave this variable name as it is
because it is storing the html text
and i'm going to re run this program and
we will probably receive a
large information of html so right now
it is not quite relevant but i'm just
i just wanted to show you the results so
let's continue from here okay so
as you know we are going to create a
beautiful soup instance
like we did in the previous episode and
i'm going to
provide the html as the html text
variable
so it will be soup equals to an
instance of a beautiful soup and then
i'm going to
write here html text as my information
that i want to
scrape and we are going to use the same
parser again
like the previous episode so it will be
lxml
now once i have done that it makes sense
to go back to
our page and see how we can grab
only this each paragraph from this
website
so the white boxes are kind of a list of
elements
that this page has provided here and i
want to
look for a method that is going to bring
me all the
job posts so it makes sense to catch
a certain element inside that post and
right click on it and then click on
inspect
and once i have done that you can see
here so i'm going to zoom in things a
little bit
so we can see that the h3 class
is pointing to that
text over here i know that the text is a
little bit small here but
just you can see that it has a gray mark
and i'm going to go up here and then you
can see that
those elements are opened up as well so
if i
hover my mouse here then you can see a
green background
wrapped in the article over here i mean
the paragraph
and then if i close that up you can see
that we have a lot of
clear fix job dash px and something like
that
that its name is the class
and our html element here is called li
so li stands for list and then you can
see that
it is inside a ul tag so
this is standing for unordered list and
it is containing
a lot of list tags inside that
ul so you can see once i close that then
the
entire list of all the posts
are marked with a blue background
so i'm going to search the element of li
with that name of class so i'm going to
copy the name of the class here
and i'm going to go back to my pycharm
and i'm going to
write here jobs equals to soup
dot find underscore all
and i'm going to search for all the lis
and as the second argument it makes
sense to pass here
class underscore equals to and then
inside
that string i'm going to paste that in
the class name that we have copied from
the page
itself so once i have done that then we
will probably see the results of all the
jobs in that page
now this doesn't mean that it is going
to bring
back all the 16 000
jobs because you can see that this
page is being paginated so that means
that it is going to bring the results
only for the first page so this is not
going to take extremely
long now if i go back to here and paste
the
jobs then let's see the results before
we continue on just to make
sure that everything is okay so we can
see that we receive
the results and then we see that we have
some company names
and i think that everything is quite
great here now in order to
work with this scraping project
it makes sense to only work with only
one job
element so i'm going to delete the
underscore all from here and what this
means it means that it is going to
bring the first match that sees the li
tag
and then the class name as this string
over here
so let's change this variable name just
to job
for now okay just in order to develop
our program
slower relying on only
one job post okay so once we've done
that we probably want to search for the
company name
of that specific job post so i'm going
to go
back to here and i'm going to make
things bigger over here
and now let's actually go here and try
to inspect
what is going on here again so let me
zoom that out great now i'm going to
try to inspect this text over here again
and then we can see that it is inside
the li tag for sure
but we can also see that it is inside an
h3
tag and it has the class name of job
list
comp name so i'm going to search
for that class in the entire page
as well but speaking about the entire
page so let's go to our pycharm
you want to search for that
specific element only inside the
job itself so you'll see it doesn't make
sense to
search for an h3 tag in the entire page
again
so you can basically go with job.find
besides soup.find because we want to
search for that h3 tag
only inside our job so if i go ahead and
print the
job here then we can see that it only
includes an html code
about only one job and i'm going to
search for
this h3 tag so let's create here a new
variable
and i'm going to call that company
underscore name
and we are going to use job.find
and we are going to accept here as an
argument
the h3 and then this time the class
underscore
is going to be equal to whatever this h3
tag includes as the class name which
is the job list comp name now to
debug this out and to ensure that the
results are great
we are going to print the company name
and then you can see that we
receive this this element back and i'm
going to
use here the dot text method just to
bring back the text itself now once i do
that
we are going to see a weird result here
now
you can see that we have some white
spaces
so we kind of want to replace our white
spaces
with nothing so in order to do
this one i'm going to go here and i'm
going to
use the replace method and this trick
is going to avoid having these not
necessary
white spaces so i'm going to replace the
spaces
with nothing so i'm going to just write
here double quotes twice
i mean single quotes twice and once i
have done that
and rerun our program then you can see
that the result is going to be quite
different as you can see this text is
fully aligned
to left now let's minimize back and
continue from here
now we're going to zoom out a little bit
the code here
just we can see the important points
like the replacement
and let's continue from here now it also
makes sense to
bring the skill requirements other than
the python programming language because
we know that
this job is only for people who
are good with the python programming
language so i'm going to
go here and i'm going to repeat myself
in the same process
again and i'm going to write here
job.find
and we are probably looking for an
element that is including a text
about the skill requirements so let's
search for that okay so let's go back to
our website again
and i'm going to go here and check
out what html element is including the
skills
so we are talking about this one so i'm
going to inspect
inside here and we can see here
that this text is inside a span class
with the class name of srp skills
so i'm going to copy again this class
name
and that time i'm going to search for
the spin
elements inside my job post
so i'm going to go back to pycharm again
and i'm going to
write here span so this is the html tag
that we are searching for
and again i'm going to write class
underscore equals to
that srp skills now i want to ensure
the results over here once again
so you always want to quickly print the
results of whatever html element that
you want to
pull to see what other methods you have
to apply
to prettify your result okay so
let's run our program again and it makes
sense to delete the print company name
so let's re-execute our program
and then you can see here that we have
some
spin tag and then here we have a strong
tag which is basically created
to make our text bold when we want to
type in something so i'm just going to
guess here that i'm going to
only write here dot text and then i
expect for the results to be
fine so let's check out for that and
then you can see here that the results
are quite great
so we have the python scripting and then
we have some more
requirements that are divided with
commas and
a lot of white spaces again so i'm going
to apply the same method of dot replace
once again like we did with the company
name so let's
write here dot replace and i'm going to
replace
white spaces with nothing so
let's re-execute that out and then we
can see that the result is quite like we
want
and now we were also able to grab the
skills as well so this is quite nice
now if we want to display a nice
information
about the job until now then we want to
go
with a nice print message here so let's
try to create a nice message so we will
use an f method here
and we will also use the triple quote
method just to
allow us to write some text in separated
lines as well
and i'm going to write here company name
like this and then i'm going to write
here
company name so i'm calling the company
name
value by writing it inside a curly
brackets
and i'm going to repeat the same process
for
required skills so it will be required
skills
and then i'm going to make that to be
equal to
skills variable and now if i go and
execute our program let's see if the
results are quite
nice yes so we kind of receiving a nice
information
about the job info okay so this is quite
great now if we go back to
here then we want to search for one more
element so you remember that i
told you that we only want to grab the
job post with the text of posted few
days ago
so we for sure want to write some extra
code to apply
this functionality so i'm going to go
here
and i'm going to inspect for that
element again
and then we can see that it is inside a
span
once again but i can also see that this
job post including some more span
tags so i have to filter out the results
again with the class name itself so i'm
going to
search for that sim posted
class name and i'm going to go back to
here
so we will write this time job
published date so it makes sense to
delete the job excuse me so it is just
going to be published date
and i'm going to go here again with
job.find
and we will search for the spin and then
this time the class
underscore is going to be equal to the
text that i just copied
and i'm going to repeat myself with
printing the published date but
that time let's just avoid printing this
print line so i'm just going to comment
out
those lines and let's see what the
published a
date text is looking like and you can
see that we have here
something a little bit weird so we have
the
span here and we have also one more span
inside of the text of it so what that
means it means that we have to take some
different action
than what we did previously so this time
i want to
search for the attribute of span just to
get inside
that tag over here and then right after
it i want to
look for the text of that span tag
so this will give me the published
date of this specific job
but i'm not going to include the publish
date inside my print message
because we only want the publish date
for the functionality
to stop our execution if the published
date text is not including the
word of few and i'm going to code this
functionality just in a second so you
will see what i mean
by what i said all right so what i'm
going to do here is take a tricky action
that is going to bring me all the
jobs from the first page so if we paid
attention
then all the job posts including this
class
name so what i can do besides the find
is change that back to underscore all
and change this variable name to jobs
and i know that just now it just raised
an error here
and i'm going to use here a for loop
that is going to
iterate over each element and i'm going
to write here
for job in jobs
and then i'm going to create an
indentation of the
entire code that is right there
so the results will be applied for all
the
jobs that are posted in the first page
of the
web page that we scrape so once i hit
here the colon sign
then i'm going to create an indentation
for each of
our lines like this and then the results
are going to be
quite the same so let's test that out
okay i'm going to
uncomment our print line over here and
just for comfort reasons
i'm also going to print here and empty
lines so we can kind of see a division
between the different jobs and then i'm
going to delete the
published date for now so if we
execute our program that time then
we are going to see a nicer results and
this is going to contain all the job
posts from the page that we scrape
against so you can see that we have a
nice paragraph for that
job post and then we have also another
one here and if i keep
scrolling up we can see a lot of them in
that
output so this is quite great so if you
remember
we wanted to filter out the job
posts that are not including the
word of few inside the published
date because what that means it means
that
this job could be outdated so if i go to
our page again then we can see that as i
keep scrolling down
we have some text like posted
six days ago and i wanted to filter out
only the jobs that are containing the
text of
posted few days ago so in order to apply
this
i'm going to change the orders here a
little bit okay so i'm going to
cut this searching here and i'm going to
paste that in as the first line inside
my for loop
now the reason i'm doing this it is
basically because i don't want to
continue on scraping for that post if
the
publish date is not matching my
condition
so it makes a lot of sense to place
this code as the first line inside my
for loop
and then right here i'm going to write a
condition
that is going to check if the word of
field is inside that text so
it will be if fill in
published date and again i'm going to
create an indentation for the entire
code
here so you can do that with the shift
alt combined and then you can just press
tab
and all the lines here are being
indented so right now if i go ahead and
execute our program then we should see
the results again like almost
the same but we also see here that
the f string is not quite nice
but i can live with that okay so it is
great that we were able to receive
the posts only that have been published
few days ago now there is no limit for
what you can
do when it comes to web scraping and
what you
can filter in or filter out but
basically this program
deals with how to grab some job posts
with the filters that you want to apply
that maybe sometimes may not be
available from the website itself
so you can write your own filtrations on
your python code
while you scrape some information from a
specific
website
so i'm going to do whatever it takes to
turn this program into
a very useful one and i'm going to do
that by applying some special
functionalities such as wrapping this
entire program in a while loop and
executing
this project every certain amount of
time and also
apply some filtrations to filter out the
job post that are not meeting the skills
that i own
and also i'm going to throw the results
of the different job
posts into a new blank file so i can be
aware of the post that are being posted
every certain amount of time so let's
get started all right then so
let's start with a kind reminder of the
results that we
got until that point so we run our
program now
and if we show it right here you can see
that
those lines are not aligned well so i'm
going to
change that and i'm also going to
provide some extra information
that will show us the exact link of the
specific job
that we are iterating on so that way i
will have the ability to just click on
the link
and then see more information about that
job
so as a beginner i will get rid of the
formatted string in that case because
doing a formatted string with a triple
quote might not be a great
idea when you execute it with a for loop
because as you can see that
it also includes the indentations right
here
so i'm going to delete this entire code
here
and i'm going to write two more new
formatted
strings and we will start with company
name
make that to be equal to company name so
make sure to add a column here so it
will be more friendly
and then i will write here required
skills as well
and then we will write here the skills
variable now there was one more issue
with
the result that we showed a minute ago
and
that was the blank spaces that
are being shown as well so we can get
rid of the spaces
by a special method that is called strip
and
it is a special method that you are
allowed to use inside
strings and since the company name and
the skills
are strings by default i don't have to
convert them to a string
so i can just call that method like
this okay and now i will show the
results of
something like the following and in a
few seconds we will see
that this is aligned way better than
what it was
and i'm also going to add here more
information
line that will show the link of the
job post so let's do that okay let's go
here and write this functionality okay
so
we had an unordered list that inside of
that
we had some different html tags that are
called li
and that stands for lists and they are
actually different
job posts that are divided into
different
elements inside an unordered list
and then if we hover our mouse you can
see that there are different
jobs now if i go inside one of them and
i
go inside a header tag that is actually
the first header of the
li tag and then i will go
inside the h2 here and then you can see
that we have
a link that could lead us to a link that
provides some extra information about
that specific
job so if i actually go here and
click on here you can see that we
receive the job description
right here so what we have to do in
order to access this link in each
job post that we are iterating on the
python code
is actually going inside and header and
then going inside one more tag
with a kind of h2 as you saw me doing
that
and then access that a tag so let's do
that okay i'm going to
go back to pycharm and apply this
functionality
so we will go under the skills
and then we will write here more info
and that will be equal to job
dot header because this was the first
tag that we want to go
inside of it and then we want to go
inside the
h2 and then inside that h2 we want to go
inside the a tag
now before we go further let's test
ourselves that we have done
great job so let's print the more
info in the following way so it will be
more info
and then we will call the variable in a
formatted string
now let's execute our program
and then you can see that inside the
more info
we have the a href which
gives us the link about the specific job
that we are iterating on
so all i have to do here is going back
to my
more info and then call that href
attribute so this time i'm going to do
that with a square
bracket like in dictionaries and then
i'm going to write here
href so i will receive the value of that
attribute so if i run that one more time
then i should see the link only and that
is what exactly happening
so the result is quite great and then
you can see that
this is already better than what we did
in the last episode
and we will continue from here okay so
what i want to do now
is giving the opportunity for the user
that executes this program
to filter out some skill requirement
that he does not own so we will use the
input function for that
and then whatever the input is equal to
we will filter out the results
from the jobs that we are finding
right here okay so let's write this
functionality
so to apply this i'm going to create a
new variable over here
and i'm going to call it unfamiliar
skill
and i'm going to make that to be equal
to an input and then i'm going to
write here something like this okay so
the user could understand
that he has to provide some information
in order to
execute this program and actually it
might be a great idea to print some
extra information
before that input function so it will be
print
put some skill that you are not
familiar with and then right after the
unfamiliar skill input i will write here
filtering out and we will actually
make that a formatted string and then we
will write here filtering
out and then whatever the unfamiliar
skill
is equal to now what are we going to do
with this unfamiliar skill variable
so that is quite easy right we have to
search for a condition that will filter
out
the job post that is including
that word that we are going to provide
here as an
unfamiliar skill and what we can
actually do is
search for the unfamiliar skill world
inside
the skills string so if you remember
the skills is a long string that
is divided with commas so we can go
with a condition like the following so
it will be
if unfamiliar skill not
inside the skills that we are
grabbing in the each job post that we
are iterating
and now all what we have to do here is
creating the indentation
for the different print lines okay so
now i should
see the job posts that are not
including the unfamiliar skill that i'm
going to
provide so just to test that out
let's run our program twice okay so
in the first we are going to write here
linux as a skill that i'm not
familiar with and you can see that we
don't see
anything that is including the keyword
of
linux over here but let's actually take
that to the next level and test that out
so we see here a specific java post that
is including
django so let's say that i am not
familiar with django
and see next time if i see that job
post with this company so
let's re-execute our program and that
time i will write
django and let's see the results
so we can see that we don't have any
job with django but we do have linux
that time so
this condition works well and we will
continue on to
next step from here now what could be an
exciting challenge for you guys
is to write an algorithm that will
accept more than one
unfamiliar skills so you want to accept
multiple inputs
from a user and it might be more
challenging
but i think you should try to spend some
time on something like this
because i think this could be an amazing
challenge for everyone who is watching
this video all right so now we are going
to save
each job post in a different file
so besides printing this in the terminal
then we are going to write this entire
information
in a separated file and then i will also
allow
this program to run every 15 minutes or
every 10 minutes up to you
and i will show this logic as well so
first of first it makes sense to wrap
our entire program
in a function and i'm going to do that
by collecting everything that is kind of
pulling the information from the website
and i'm going to
indent everything one step aside and
then i'm going to
right here def find
jobs okay so that way we have one
function that executes our main
program and then what i'm going to do
here
is using the logic of if double
underscore name is
double underscore main so that way if
you want to extend
this program only if this file is ran
directly then this function will be
executed
now if you don't know what i said about
if double underscore name equals
double underscore main then i have a
video that explains this condition
so you can check that out by the
suggested link above
so let's write here if double underscore
name equals to double underscore main
inside a string and then right here
while true so i want to run this program
forever and then i will call the find
jobs and right after it since i don't
want
this program to being executed like
every
millisecond then i'm going to write here
time dot sleep so time dot sleep
allows your program to wait certain
amount of time
that you decide and you can provide its
argument by
seconds so i'm going to write here 600
just to make that program to run every
10
minutes but you can notice how we did
not import the time library so
let's do that by import time
okay and then this program should be
okay now
to make this more dynamic i actually
prefer to
make some variable here that will be
equal to 10
and then i will just make that to be
equal to time weight
multiplied by 60 and right after it
we can provide some extra information
excuse me this should be over here
and we can write here waiting
let's make it formatted then we can
write here waiting
time weight seconds and let's write
three dots here
great so this is great so if i'm
executing this program i expect to see
this program
running every 10 10 minutes so i'm
inside
my command line interface and you can
see that my
directory has been already set to the
directory
where we worked so i can go
with python and then execute the name of
the file by calling it so it will be
main.pi and then once i run that
you can see that we receive this output
and then i have to provide some
information that is going to
be filtered out and then let's write
here django
again and you can see that we
receive the results successfully but
more
important we see that waiting 10 seconds
which is not great we have to change
that to waiting 10 minutes because
we are waiting 10 minutes right but the
program
works great it was just my mistake by
writing here
seconds so it should be minutes for sure
but i'm not going to wait 10 minutes
until this program is running one more
time
and so i will allow myself to move on to
writing this information inside file
so it makes sense to write this kind of
information in a separated
directory so i will go inside my
web scraping tree file i mean folder and
then i'm going to
create here new directory which is going
to be
named as posts and then i'm going to
write here some extra functionality that
will create files i mean text files
then and then inside each text file i'm
going to
write this exact information so you can
do that
by with open i already show you
how you can do that in the first episode
now i know that i don't have any
separated tutorial about working
with files in python but you want to
consider check out my channel maybe i
will upload very soon
so you can go here and that time
i want to put here information and i
will call my post
directory and then inside here
i have to provide my file name that i'm
going to
create now before i move on here
i thought about changing my for loop
here
and use the enumerate function now
enumerate function is going to allow us
to
iterate over the index of the
jobs list and also the job
content itself and so i have to provide
here
one more variable like index so the
index
is going to be a kind of counter for the
job that i'm iterating on and then the
job
variable will relate to the job
beautiful sub object itself and so it
makes sense to
name our files with the index of the job
that i'm iterating on
so i will change this into a formatted
string and then i will
write here index dot txt so it will be
something like the following
and i expect each my text file to be
named like
0.txt or 1.txt
and so on now the second argument
will be the permission level that you
want to
give when you create or open a new file
and this time i'm going to write here w
and
that stands for writing inside the file
and then i have to use the as statement
and i'm going to use the f variable so
inside that block i can write
to a file with the f variable
and i'm going to go inside my with open
and i'm going to create indentation of
the prints
and i'm going to delete this print line
here
and it makes sense to remove this blank
space as well
and all i have to do here is changing
this print statement to f
dot write and then that time i'm not
going to
print the results in the command line
interface
besides i'm going to write the
information
in a new file so i'm going to use the
combination of alt
shift here and i'm going to change
those entire three prints to f
dot right okay and then i'm going to
open the parentheses
so it will be closed by those
and then i expect for each job to
being written inside a file
and once i do that it might be a great
idea to print
a sentence like file saved
and then you can provide the name of the
file as an extra information so i will
create one more time formatted string
and then i will relate to that index
variable and now our program is complete
so let's check it okay let's go back to
our command line interface
and let's actually control break this
program
and let's write cls to clear our
terminal
and then i'm going to re-execute my
program so it will be python
main dot pi and then i'm going to
execute it so let's see this time i'm
going to write
django as well and that time
i don't expect to see output for the
information
besides i expect to see this okay so
let's see
what is inside each of our files so
let's see what is inside that post
directory okay so i'm going to go inside
my
c python put web scripting tree and then
the post
directory that we created a few minutes
ago and you can see that
inside of that we have our text files
but if i go here inside let's see if the
results are okay
okay so i'm not quite satisfied with
with that because
it might be a greater idea to see that
like
i mean like this okay so you might
want to divide those information in
separated lines
but that is not going to be complex so
we just have to go
inside our python again and then
whenever we write to the file
we have to use that convention where you
can just
jump a line and that will be backslash
in so when you provide backslash n
inside a string it is just a convention
that is going to jump to the next line
right after it so it will be backslash
n for the first line and then also here
and
let's run this program one more time so
i'm just going to break the program
and re-execute it so that time i will
write
linux and then let's test our results
one more time so
let's go inside our 19.txt
and then you can see that the
information is right there
just like we expected okay so this is
quite
great alright guys so i hope you enjoyed
this entire
series and you can find everything that
we have done here
by the links in the description of
course i will provide
extra information in my website about
this series
so if you like this video consider
subscribing and also
hit the like button i will see you in my
future uploads